let's let's do it let's let's do it
let's do it let's let's do it and we
live
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Applause]
all right today Pete Davidson Taco Bell
Pete he's getting a lot of heat I don't
understand why
Seahawk is getting good how's the dragon
too many time jumps
uh plus what else
[Music]
foreign
yeah anyways uh yeah we got a lot of
stuff we're gonna go over today
um yeah so uh what else uh Draymond
Green situation uh I want to go over
there and I want to follow up from last
week's little talk about Little Mermaid
uh today's background I don't know if
this is distracting or not let me know
chat you know I'm just trying to change
it up it's got this like fiery these are
the fire Embers going I don't know it
just looks like I'm on fire we'll keep
it maybe that's good for House of
dragons
um so welcome to live chat everybody
Welcome to riffing with Griffin once
again I forgot to change the main title
so it still says that up you know oh
well there you go no idea it looks good
oh maybe maybe I'm using the wrong uh
what do you call it the wrong file but
it don't matter uh make sure you
subscribe share
and all that good stuff you know make
sure you do that I appreciate you guys
for that and once again as you know I'm
on Twitch daily Eric Griffin gaming
which I'll be going live after this
before I head to my show before I head
to Hollywood and if you want to support
the show with extra content coming just
Rachel's been working but we gonna do
that uh whatever I might I put gaming
content on here put whatever content I
can or if it's just you just want to
support me which I appreciate too and
remember I do have merch and all that
kind of stuff on my website this I'm
trying to get some I'm trying to get
some new merch I need some new designs
so if you're a designer out there you
want to help me out let me know
uh for that but anyways then guys thanks
for being here thanks for the support
um dates I got coming up this Thursday I
think it's Thursday Friday it's Friday
Saturday Sunday or even Thursday then
they're having a welcome party on
Thursday but I'm in skank Fest so look
for me on skank Fest this weekend in
Vegas it's like weird show time so make
sure you make sure you if you look into
specifically to see me make sure you
look and see uh when I'm performing
um because they got shows like in the
middle of the day too so make sure you
check that out then I'm doing a show
with Rick Glassman I'm going to St
Petersburg with Rick you can go to
Rick's stuff to find out the information
about that go to Rick glass go to go to
Rick glassman's Instagram go to I
believe Rick has a website but you can
find out that information there it's in
St Petersburg Tampa which is next
weekend uh 21st and 22nd I believe that
is and then I'm gonna be at the Colusa
Casino in Sacramento area uh on on the
28th so come check me out there
uh big big Casino gig for me so it
should be fun so come check me out if
you guys are interested in that so hello
welcome back to Griffin with Griffin
River
and weekly stays uh still doing it right
so what happened this week
um yeah Rachel got a job so she's
working some modeling job the next
couple days uh so good for her shout out
to her I do want to have Rachel's watch
we still want to watch some of these
Marvel movies just trying to figure out
which ones to watch I think I want to
watch the major ones you know like I
want to watch
um
like I want to watch I want her to watch
like Captain America Thor those big ones
and then the first Avengers and then
we'll go to the end just to get her
reviews but you know it's like as I said
I don't think she really likes them so
what happened this week so I went to uh
I I don't know all the married people
out there shout out to all the Mary
people we we went to uh my ring so I
don't have my wedding ring on right now
because we took it in uh I got my
wedding ring from Tiffany's shout out to
Tiffany's I just got Rachel's engagement
ring there so I just said you know let's
get just get my ring there too but it
didn't fit properly it doesn't fit
properly I don't know if anybody has
that issue you know I don't know like
who are men to where do you wear a
wedding ring do you like wearing a
wedding ring ladies that listen to all
six of you do you want your man to wear
a wedding ring do you do you need him to
wear it you know what I mean like you
need him to be wearing your wedding ring
like what is the thing that makes it
um
you know what what's the thing that
makes it like important to you so but
anyways the ring like it just doesn't
fit good like so like if I if I wash my
hands the ring comes off you know what I
mean
um oh Jeremy thanks for joining and you
can also be a YouTube member too so we
have a new YouTube member so if you want
to be a YouTube member too you can
support me there too but anyways the
ring was slipping off my finger so every
time I take a shower or something like
that I take it off actually the other
like about a couple weeks ago I took my
ring off to take a shower and I put it
in uh you know I've had it
I put it down and then I was in a rush
and I forgot to put it back on so when I
came home I forgot about it right you
know just I went to bed I woke up and
then I was like looking for it and I
thought I put it in a certain spot I
knew it was there and it wasn't there so
I just went looking but I had again I
had to leave so then I finally go hey
Rachel have you seen my ring and then
Rachel's like yes I seen your ring you
just left it I put and then she took it
and put it someplace and I was like well
where's my ring she was like you out
here acting single
I was like I'm not acting single I just
couldn't find the ring
I actually want to go like to Amazon and
buy some like rubber rings just uh you
could always have it so like right now I
don't have it because we took it in to
get it cleaned and get it resized I
think I'm size 10 and I think it was
like a bigger size because you want it
to go on and maybe it's not hard to get
on but you know you could tell it's like
a thing and then it just you could just
shake your finger and it won't come off
so I don't know it was just funny to me
that she was like you out here acting
single
so we went to um I took Rachel to this
restaurant called True Foods and I'm not
trashing True Foods at all it's actually
really good but we had this weird
experience so we go to True Foods daily
out in Santa Monica and again shout out
to them it's really good food it's
healthy I just wanted to eat some I just
wanted to be at a place where there's a
lot of healthy options but also
delicious you know what I mean and when
you're trying because I'm because my
weight loss and my health goals are
still intact you know I've been working
out you know if I don't do it daily I do
it every other day uh on my rowing
machine and it really feels good and
then I've also cut back on eating a lot
of sugars and stuff like that like
the only sweets that I add extra like
words this is extra because a lot of
things come with sugar and you don't
even realize it or it processes into
sugar I'm not talking about those things
you know like if you have a little rice
so you know rice does that so what are
you supposed to do right I'm just
talking about like I'm not having cakes
and pies and that kind of stuff the only
sweet thing I add is I put honey in my
coffee in the mornings so I'll have
honey oat milk in my coffee I'm all
about the honey and the coffee but
apparently you're supposed to have a
spoonful of Honey a day that's supposed
to help you but whatever you know
there's always something people are
talking about right
so we go to True Foods so I take witches
to this like healthy restaurant True
Food daily right so we've eat the food
it's great she has like a healthy Pizza
whatever it was and I had like I had a
turkey burger you know I had a you know
on a a flaxseed bun with some nonsense
like that it was really delicious I felt
fulfilled I had a kale salad so the the
waitress comes up to us afterwards and
she's all like hey would you guys like
dessert and I immediately was like no
I'm good on dessert I'm cool because
even healthy but she's like hey are you
interested in dessert because I have a
story about our cookies
so then she goes into this cookie story
about well our cookies are chocolate
chip cookies and they are they are
binded together with bananas and it's
vegan gluten-free no sugar and it's just
all this stuff whatever the cookies come
and it comes with some coconut ice cream
thing everything's vegan the cookies
were nasty as hell
hey
vegan people okay straight up
stop trying to make sweets stop trying
to make stuff that you want to eat
you you're not doing a good job okay
these cookies were nasty as hell you
know what it would have been better
if they would have sliced up a banana
and put a piece of chocolate on top of
the banana and serve that been like
here's some bananas with a little
chocolate on it I would have been like
oh delicious this is good you know what
I mean because what they tried to do to
make it look like like by the way it
looked like a cookie but it was smoking
mirrors man
it was gooey and nasty and I was like
this is not a cookie I know what a
cookie tastes like and I'm not supposed
to have a cookie so I don't want a
cookie but I don't want your nasty
cookie you know what I'm saying like
this vegan like I just don't get it man
I just don't get it you know it's like
sometimes you just you don't have that
just have your vegan stuff have your
healthy stuff be it just have salads
just have tofu whatever it is it's gonna
look like but stop trying to make your
nasty food look like food that's good
because it's not good you just it's just
disappointing me when I bite it am I
trying to visually fool myself and be
like well this looks like a cookie so it
must be a cookie now man because when I
take a bite of that cookie I'd like to
say the goddamn cookie it's nasty ah
it would be like like say you haven't
like oh you're having vegan sex you know
oh here's vegan sex so there's no
penetration no skin to skin
you know what I mean you can't even be
in the same room but we calling it sex
you'd be like just don't feel the same
it's not the same so stop trying to make
me feel like it's the same once again
the ingredients you have in the cookie
just serve me that
just serve me that on a little portion
of that just serve me a little portion
of bananas and chocolate with maybe some
kind of granola some kind of thing and
you'd be like oh this is a healthy
dessert as opposed to being like well
let's take all these healthy things
let's scrunch them all together and make
it look like it's a real cookie this
ain't a real cookie okay I know what a
real cookie tastes like and I shouldn't
be having that because I'm trying to
lose weight so this thing that's going
on all you making me do is feeling bad
that I don't have a damn real cookie
okay so stop it
anyways
that's my cookie rant so that's what you
went on all right guys I I want to
follow up on last week's episode okay uh
because I I put this out there and wait
I don't even know if this is the right
um
I don't know if I
I don't know if I made a picture a
background picture but anyways
um you know what I'm sick of this I
wanna I Wanna Get rid of this if you
know if you watch it on YouTube later if
you're if you're listening and thank you
for listening on all the listening
platforms this was a little calmer right
the fire was too much I'm back to the
Stars so last week I was talking about
Little Mermaid and just how I thought
it was more stupid than anything else
that people were upset that they've made
Little Mermaid black well I got a lot of
uh interesting comments on Instagram
some people I feel like just don't get
it okay they don't get my point all
right so I want to reiterate my point
because here's the thing that I found so
kind of funny and interesting
so anytime I brought up a lot of people
brought this up you know there's this
first of all I don't think people really
know the origins of Little Mermaid uh
you know that the author it goes back
way far okay like the guy that wrote
this was like the original story was
like he's Dutch or something like that
Danish you know and you know he wrote
this story you know this is like you
know it's like for people to think that
they have some kind of claim on the
racial thing of it it's like look
writers write what's going on in their
times and at that particular time
everything was white there wasn't any
you know it's just it just is what it is
and there's nothing it doesn't mean that
there was a racial like racism tone to
it I don't want to come across like that
okay but I think that you know people
today who would just they just had this
visceral reaction uh I think that there
are white people who
who don't like any time there's
something like this that they don't like
being called racist that they think
everything's racist like oh man it's
racist that I don't like this okay so I
get that they're pushing back because of
that but that's not what I'm talking
about like don't bring your anger about
other things that are going on society
to me that's not what I'm saying let me
reiterate this again
I don't care like you can't even get to
it being racist or prejudiced because
it's so stupid it's stupid to be
concerned about this fictional character
now this is what I take offense to that
this is what so many white
non-black let's just say that we're
doing they left it may use this example
well what if we made black panther white
that's their big argument they think
that is a genius argument and they think
it's the same thing what if we made
black panther white black community
would go crazy
all right
let me debunk this because once again
this ain't about race for me okay
there are some extreme sort of white
people that watch my podcast to hate and
they look at me they're always saying
this to me oh you're super woke tank if
you really watch my podcast you know my
[__] ain't woke at all I'm anti-woke
okay let's just go through this step by
step
I think it's stupid to be
worried about the race change of a
completely fictional character from a
fictional place and a fictional being
mermaid
mermaids aren't real
and in this story they come from a place
that's not real
and so therefore the interpretation of
what that could be could be anything
now
black panther is completely different
this made-up location of wakanda
in the Marvel universe is located in
Africa
and it is a tribe that goes back
generations and generations therefore it
makes sense that that character is black
okay
if you want to make wakanda in South
Africa
if wakanda was in South Africa then
maybe yeah that you want to make the
dude you want to change the whole story
that way you make that movie you uh you
you give the backstory origin story that
they did that were condos in South
Africa and this is a tribe of white
Africans if you want to do that more
happy I'm more than happy or you want to
have a backstory where there was a
European boat and then they a baby got a
kid fell off and then an African tribe
found this white baby and they made this
white baby black panther in this you
want to do that fine
but my point about Little Mermaid and my
point about Black Panther
just take that for face value Little
Mermaid is a fictional character from a
fictional place that doesn't exist like
if is is the is the crab gonna be
Jamaican still
are you gonna be upset if they change
the crap you know you know they were
singing Kiss the Girl there you see her
sitting there across the way are you
gonna change that if that person's not
Jamaican are you guys gonna be upset
um I wonder
it doesn't matter
so
stop making the argument about Black
Panther
you want to change blade go right ahead
but it could be white asian Mexican
whatever
another guy brought up Luke Cage oh Luke
Cage is a k is a character that was
fighting against racial Injustice he
should be non-white that just because of
the origin story this for me has nothing
to do with race so much as it has to do
with it needs to make sense
that's all I want I need it to make
sense so for you to come at with this
argument
it's like it's
like think about what you're saying
if you are having a problem with
white people
unnecessarily being called racist I'm
with you a hundred percent okay I'm with
you you can't just jump to racism and
are there people jumping on this issue
because of that hell yeah because that's
what the woke culture people do man
that's what people do they they like to
jump on and be like oh yeah oh let's get
on white people again I ain't about that
life man I was supposed to talk about
this show last week and I actually
didn't even put it in the notes but
there's a a show out right now called
Interview with the Vampire and it's
based off Anne Rice's novels Interview
with the Vampire and there used to be uh
there was already a movie and it was
starred Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt okay
now um wait let me look this up because
I was supposed to talk about this last
week and I just forgot uh
and um okay so I
I read the books man
um interviews and it's on AMC plus uh so
I actually I actually got AMC plus
um you know because man I'm just paying
for too many cable things by the way
you know wait let me look this up
Interview with a Vampire AMC AMC you
know I just want to get like the picture
of it AOC plus interview
AMC oh here we go here's the IMDb okay
here's the IMDb yeah baby yeah baby all
right let's go to screen capture so you
guys can see it all right so here's uh
Interview with a Vampire you know it's
on AMC plus it's Stars uh who's this
star Jacob Anderson Sam Reed and Eric
bogas bogashan hope I said that right
you guys know I'm terrible with names
um
so here's my thing about
this video on the reason why I'm
bringing this up so they've changed the
character of Louis in the books let me
go back even further I've read Interview
with a Vampire I've read Interview with
a Vampire Vampire Lestat I told you guys
you guys if you watch my podcast you
know I love vampire stuff so I've read
these books okay I've read the books
they're great
um it kind of went off the rails like
Queen of the Damned remember the singer
Aaliyah they think they made a movie
about that too she sadly R.I.P Aaliyah
she died but she was in that movie you
know it wasn't a very good movie but
either way so I've read these books now
I remember reading these books a long
time ago and thinking this
that it seems to me that like the
vampires represent
um the gay community
it just felt like that even when I when
I was reading it I was like oh there's a
lot of like sort of like vampire on
vampire romance and I think that she's
writing this book to you know four gay
people okay that's what I I don't know
if that's true or not but in back in the
day that's what I that's what I took
from it I have no problem with that I
just I'm not going to say it's it's I
love vampire stuff and it's a great
story it's a great
story okay so KATU they've now updated
the story and they've made the main one
of the main characters this sort of
light-skinned black guy and who lived in
New Orleans and
at first when I first saw it I was like
well here they go because they're doing
this a lot there's another show I like
to watch there's another book I read
called Vampire Academy and they just
made that into a series on peacock
um and I watched that one too and they
made the main character in that story I
don't
I believe she's black like you know but
she's very ethnic you know it looks like
she's mixed another She's mixed which is
yay for me I love mixed race stuff show
me the mixed race people right and that
one but again your first initial thought
when you see this is like well this
looks very like a woke agenda right but
then you go from that to like well it's
fine like who cares right
um as long as it's good but I know
initially that's my first thought too
because it's like like I say before
things have been white for so long when
it's not white We're triggered to be
like why isn't this white which you
shouldn't be like that but it just is
what it is man it's you know it's you
know black people make up 13 of the
population so for things or to be a lot
of [__] being white it makes sense right
they're speaking to their people
whatever the majority of the people in
the country are white okay it's like I
don't know why we can't say that without
people people being offended by that
it's you know you talk about it's about
money and it's selling stuff and all
whatever okay so they made that
character black I watched the show after
a few episodes I don't even think about
it anymore and make makes sense to me
it's fine this interview with a vampire
same thing
sometimes you watch something and it
don't make sense that the person they've
changed the race or something you'd be
like well that's kind of weird you know
because me personally I've gone out for
parts where initially you could tell
that this was written for all white
people and then somebody up above was
like oh man we can't just make an
all-white show or all white whatever
let's change this character whatever and
then I go in and I'm reading for a
character of Todd oh this is Todd and
you're reading the character and you're
like I think Todd should be white but
okay I get where you're trying to change
it you probably should change a lot of
this stuff you know and it's not even
just race stuff either man I'm doing uh
I'm doing this HBO Max show right now
I'm doing three episodes of this show
right and like I'm reading the script my
part and then like later in the script
they're referencing my character and it
says uh the guy my character's name
somebody asked the main guy hey how's
so-and-so and he in the line is he goes
well he lost a lot of weight but I liked
him better when he was fat or something
like that right so when I finally got on
set because I I got the part I said to
the Creator and the star I was like Hey
I was reading the script and you
probably want to change that line
because I'm still a big I'm a big guy
that's just what happens sometimes you
have to go in now and adjust so it's
like if you're writing a character
that's like he's white and he has a
white upbringing and you haven't thought
of the backstory if you're gonna change
him to say Asian Latino black whatever
that person has a whole different origin
story that they got to this point and
that's what you have to think about
that's why I'm saying when it comes to
Racial equality and that kind of stuff
it needs to start at the production
level it needs to start that like you're
making a show about a guy and he has a
black friend well you know it's like
well this is why he has a black friend
maybe there's they live in the suburbs
and this is a black guy who's like his
parents were upwardly mobile and needed
or is it somebody that like oh he came
from this kind of community and whatever
like just give us a little backstory and
we're fine with it that's what I think
we are fine with it right so as I look
at interview with a Vampire my point I'm
making is like this is so well done
they've upgraded the story they've
they've like so it's loose it's based
off the book but now more modern times
like in the book uh the the the vampire
Louis is trying to like reveal he's he's
trying to he's telling his story to a
reporter who is going to write a book uh
or like write an article or something
like exposing the vampire community so
the whole book is about him telling his
origin story uh meeting this Vampire
Lestat right so they sort of upgraded it
in this in this series as if they it's
like this reporter was talking about it
with him say 40 years ago and now
they're re-picking it up again because
they didn't get to finish it because
Lestat messed it up so now they're
starting over I love how they're doing
it the actor is great the story is great
they make it make sense it's like an
origin story explaining why this black
guy uh is who he is and I don't even
think about it anymore and that's all we
want is [__] to be well done
I went on a tangent anyways
anyways you know when it comes just to
bring it back all I'm saying is
you really should think about
why you're upset about
a thing like I I read something
um about actually somebody commented on
the thing saying that actually The
Little Mermaid is was uh really supposed
to represent the author himself who was
gay and trying to show how he had to
change to live in regular Society it was
uh analogy on that you know but all
these like sort of like white guys who
were like trying to come at me like why
are they changing to be true to the
story oh do you really want to be true
to the story I don't think they even
know I think it's just a backlash of
like just constantly being told you're
wrong and evil and I'm not trying to do
that y'all I'm not but there is
something to me that is stupid about
caring about that for this instance it
being Little Mermaid that's all I'm
saying and for you to bring up Black
Panther and think that that's a good
example that is also stupid
full stop
all right
let's go into some other stuff man all
right so as you guys I don't know if you
guys are into basketball
um
I'm into basketball man and there's this
whole thing right now about I don't know
if you guys know about
Draymond Green from the Golden State
Warriors if you haven't heard about it
right now
uh you know he got into an altercation
at
practice with Jordan Poole and you know
as you can see right here it got really
contentious and it looks like he
uh you know Jordan Poole's saying him
he's John and saying something to him
and then you know General comes up on
him he pushes him and they dream I'm
getting [__] decks him and probably
would have knocked him out okay
all right I want to go through this now
step by step on how I feel about this
okay
all right
I think that I've I remember being in
high school
and playing basketball
you get heated with your teammates man
on any level that you're playing
anything Sports even when you're playing
video games with your friends things get
heated if you ever listen to me on
Twitch
with my buddy Vincent oshana shout out
to Vinnie man sometimes we go at each
other it is what it is it's part of it
okay
because we're live we never take it too
far but when teammates friends people
that are close work together they have
fights it gets out of hand
you deal with it if it's too much you
deal with it you deal with it in-house
okay
and I think that to go in the state
where I have no problem with them
fighting who knows what Jordan Poole
said to him sometimes people go too far
sometimes you say sometimes your mouth
writes a check your face can't cash and
that's probably what happened in this
situation I don't know why they fought I
don't know what he said
could be about money off-court stuff
could be about whatever they want but
professional athletes have egos they are
ego maniacal Maniacs that's how they're
able to be good they're delusional they
think that they're the greatest athlete
in the world that's what brings out the
greatness in them that's just what we
have to deal with that just they're just
phenomenal human specimens and they're
out here doing this thing and things
happen okay they fight things happen
so fine now next step is this
no matter what happens man if you're
texting with your buddies on a group
text and you are saying some stuff that
is inappropriate which we all do
you're talking with your buddies you're
saying inappropriate things if somehow
those text messages reach the public you
then have to answer for them
okay you answer for them because they
got out into the public and people's
feelings were hurt
that's what happens
I don't like when people then
you know
attack someone's character because of
private correspondence
okay but when those correspond when that
comes out I do believe you have to
answer for it that's what Draymond Green
has done
he has now apologized and and how I like
how he apologized he was like look I
know Jordan's father his mother his
family saw this and I have to answer for
that
in the same way too the Draymond Green's
mother is out here defending him
punching because that's what she has to
do because that's her kid right because
that got out all these people are now
affected and everyone has to put in
their two cents
so I believe that he handled it the way
he needed to handle it because it came
out
now here's my real problem
whoever put this video out needs to be
fired
this is some in-house
nobody else's business stuff
this video should have never gone out
but this is the kind of society we live
in now where it has to be some sort of
gotcha so we can attack people so we can
like now for entertainment purposes it
should have never ever gotten out and I
hope they find out the [__] that put
this out because that person is a coward
ass [__]
that's what I say right I hope you're
listening I hope you see this
what you did is traitorous that traitor
ass [__] should be fired
give them his Walking Papers and get him
the hell out of there if it's somebody
that like works at this wherever they go
like this they should say they should
take their business elsewhere all right
take their business elsewhere
because this is not something that you
be getting out into the public man for
public consumption they had an in-house
fight that they should have handled in
house
you fight with your brothers you fight
with whoever you're fighting with and if
it's a personal thing because you guys
are really close and you work together
that's nobody else's business it's
nobody else's business
but if you
but like I say again but once it gets
out you then have to answer for it and
if you have some terrible horrible
behavior on that tape or whatever you
have to answer for it regardless I'm not
I'm not saying Draymond Green was right
I'm not saying what's his name was right
this was a terrible situation Draymond
Green should be punished for that and I
I would have wanted them to handle that
in-house we would I just wanted to hear
them say yeah we had some internal
strife there was a fight amongst
teammates and it's being handled that's
all we need to hear the fact that they
put this out in public like this whoever
did this man that shit's terrible
you know I don't think the Warriors put
it out no I think it was put out and
then they got on top of it you know what
I mean I don't think the Warriors put
this out man no this don't look like
something that the Warriors would put
out man whoever I think this is like TMZ
got a whole I think somebody was like
ooh let me get this a chance to make
money you know what I mean so I don't
know man I just I just I don't like it I
don't like it I think it's like you know
it's like now this is why like
this is why now you hear like some huge
comics when you come to their shows they
make you put the cell phone in a bag
because man in that environment as a
comic you're working things out and you
might say something sometimes when
you're working it out it don't sound
right yet and so now we don't even have
a spot that we can go and try this out
in front of a crowd and then the
response we get from the crowd we'll be
like uh you know what I didn't say that
right or I need to adjust these words
now people want to be in the show and
they want to record you and then they
want to put that out on the internet oh
look what this comic said and it's like
that's so odd it's out of context it's
unfair to the situation and I just think
that no matter what is going on like let
people handle that like can we just have
this moment like they had a moment man
they had a moment it was a terrible
moment and they need to handle that and
it's none of our business
it's none of our business man
you know and so now
unfairly or fairly Draymond Green has to
now answer for his you know Behavior now
look guys
something like this comes out and you're
a person that has a history of doing
stuff then yeah maybe it's like yo
you're not getting the benefit of the
doubt because you know you cost your
team a championship because of your
outburst
you know what I mean it is what it is
I saw somebody
in the chat say
oh horrible take I'm out bye
it's like this is how people are they
don't they don't listen to the whole
thing you know what I mean
so I don't know
I'll say again this tape should have
never gotten out
if this tape was leaked by someone who
works there
if it was somebody that was just in the
gym was like ooh let me film this look
what's going on and they that I just
think the whole thing is terrible I bet
you nothing like this comes out again I
bet you it's gonna be I bet you it's
gonna be like a uh uh closed practice
moving forward
I bet you all NBA teams are now like hey
who's in the gym right now I bet you
they looking around now like who's in
the gym I bet you every NBA team sat
down and was like Hey guys uh you know
we gotta keep a close we gotta we gotta
keep things uh close to our chest now
make sure when you're in the gym act
accordingly because you never know who's
taping
and you know you might have the opinion
that yeah be on your p's and q's at all
times I'm saying you in a comfortable
environment where you know it's
loosey-goosey and you you your temper's
flare I mean it happens I'm not excusing
it I'm just saying these kind of things
happen the fact that the person put that
out
I'm not with it that's my take you don't
like it I don't care is what it is but
that is terrible you know and like and
like at the same time you go all right
maybe they sold that to TMZ and they got
whatever amount of money fine you got
them on this one but moving forward
they've made it very difficult now for
just like a person who just wants to go
to the gym so now I bet you if you're in
the gym you gotta sign an NDA
you know what I mean I bet it's gonna be
like that now anybody in the gym all
Personnel even people that work in the
facility are now going to have to sign
an NDA or something like that I just I
bet that's what is gonna happen moving
forward and I think so
you know what I mean I think so
anyways
that's my
take
all right
um
so anyways
I hope you I know you guys agree
disagree you know like I say anything I
talk about I'd love we can have a
discourse in the in the comments you
know what I mean you can write in the
comments you can write on Instagram it's
just let's just have like a you know a a
calm back and forth some people you can
like even if you don't agree with me
it's okay to be heated if you don't
agree with me it should be but like say
your point like let's have a like have a
discussion about it don't have a thing
where you're like you know that's how
people want to be it's like if if you if
I don't agree with you or you don't
agree with me it has to be you're a
idiot and you know then it's like it's
never about like trying to make a point
or hearing the other person's point so
you know you need you need to you need
to have that
um
well like somebody said in the thing
what if Warriors wouldn't punish Dre at
least people they straight this pool has
support now we'll see that I don't I
don't I would like to think that that's
not the case you know what I mean but
you never know you know what I mean so
like again regardless of the aftermath
what I'm saying is you're just talking
about one benefit of a horrible thing
that happened you know what I'm saying
so this horrible thing happened this
tape got out so one of the benefits of
that is oh you think Jordan pool is now
getting support but I've seen things
where people talk about that that people
are talking about oh he deserved to get
punched because he said this and he's
doing this off the court whatever that
is I don't know I'm not going to talk
about it I don't care about people's
business that way so you never know like
the support who knows if he's getting
support or not like y'all the the
internet support is fake support you
know internet support's not real Twitter
and all that stuff is not real people
can say that they're woke and they can
do all this canceling or whatever things
they want it don't translate to real
people taking action for instance the
movie Bros the the the gay Love Story
movie it completely tanked nobody went
to watch it it tells me that Twitter's
not real like you can say all you want
about support and all this kind of stuff
people didn't go to this they didn't
flock to the theaters to see that movie
because it's only the loud minority on
the internet who are saying you know
it's like I needed if the movie's funny
I need somebody to tell me hey this
movie's really funny you want to go see
it and I'll be like all right or not I
mean the box office is way down right
now because nobody's going to see any
movies really it's only a certain number
of movies or even getting any kind of
love so you know there's just a lot of a
lot of things like that so what I'm
saying is the support you may think he
would have gotten that's just a small
positive if you think it's positive but
it still doesn't take away from the
whole thing about this thing getting out
the way it did
you know someone else said what if he
was allowed to record okay if he was
allowed to record
how did it get to TMZ see you see what
I'm saying like that makes it even worse
so let's say there is somebody up there
like okay record practice so we can see
and then that person took that and sold
it that's even worse
so it's a matter of like to me I would
like to know the backstory of like how
did this get out
why'd this person do this it's a
betrayal to the team and like the
privacy of the team and I think that
person should be fired if they work for
the team and now they have to change
what they do
you know
and listen I see someone else I I agree
with you Draymond Green was way out of
line
to flush punch someone that you are
seven inches and maybe 60 pounds heavier
than that that was that wasn't the way
but he had think has admitted himself
that he was going through something no
excuse that's exactly what makes it bad
all I'm saying is like that's what I
went through it step by step I am in no
way condoning any any of his actions but
I just think every step of the way was
handled the way it was supposed to be
handled you know I think Draymond Green
has taken full responsibility because of
what he you know because it was it got
out it's not like he went on to the
podium and was like he's not even saying
like oh man that dude was running his
mouth and he got what he deserved no
Draymond B is like I'm a leader I made a
mistake I apologize to him his family I
apologize to my team I'm stepping away
from the team right now I'm working on
myself I'm like you know like he did
everything right in the aftermath of the
video coming out and I I commend him on
that okay but the fact that all this I I
would I would I don't think it should be
in the public eye I think it should they
should have been handled it in house
it should have been handled in house
that's what I say about that all right
y'all
so
it is what it is
um
you know what I mean
so
there you go
all right what else is there you know I
got I got more stuff to talk about
oh that'll be a heavy discussion all
right so this is a silly one to me so
apparently
you know Reddit which is like you know
Reddit is like a dive bar
Reddit is like
um
like some sort of like
you know what I mean like some sort of
like I always think red is like a biker
bar that you're not allowed to go in
unless you remember you know it's like I
feel like it's like a biker bar and you
walk in there if you walk in there on on
you know Uninvited people are gonna just
hope the music's gonna stop and
everybody's gonna look at you like what
are you doing here stranger you know so
you know there's a lot of crazy stuff on
Reddit so I just I stay away from Reddit
but a big one is just about Pete
Davidson poor Pete Davidson man the dude
can't catch a break
but apparently they're getting on him
for eating with his mouth open you know
what I mean but this is like a big ass
Taco Bell whatever breakfast sandwich
thing that you eat probably after you
had like a a night out are you drunk at
night or you wake up in the morning and
you hung over and you want a nasty
breakfast you go here so they it's so
like they they're getting on him because
of how he was eating this and I just
think it's like damn I mean that's the
internet man you can't the internet is
like you can pick apart the smallest
moment from
from something and just tear somebody
down man I've met Pete a few a few times
you know you know it's like when Pete
was coming up when he was just just
starting out I was headlining the show
in New Jersey and he was like to feature
you know what I mean and now please you
know I I'd have to open for him and he
and I'm probably not big enough to do
that you know what I mean so it's like
I've always been nice to Pete uh you
know I think that he's he's he got an
aura or something about him that people
love hating people love loving people
love talking about and obviously women
love them some Pete right
you know what I mean like he's like you
know it's like Tom Brady better look out
his ex-wife is next or his soon-to-be
ex-wife might be next so it's just weird
like it's just a weird-ass stories about
like and if and the commercials are
actually funny
I think the commercials are like I think
they asked him hey what do you want to
do and he kind of gave his input and go
hey let's do this and the commercials
totally suit his personality you know so
good for Taco Bell they're just like hey
let's get Taco Taco Bell's like hey
let's just get Pete Davidson you know
what I mean it's it's almost as if Kim
Kardashian herself is doing a commercial
because he's just associated with
everything so
I don't know
I don't know what
I don't even know what more to even say
about it just something fun
to uh end it on but yeah it just seemed
kind of it just seems like a weird thing
to be upset about right but I mean it is
what it is I guess like it shows how
famous he is like you're so famous that
you could how you eat a sandwich
is like newsworthy
you know
like how you eat a sandwich uh makes
people be like damn why is he eating
that sandwich that way
so I don't know
it is what it is shout out but shout out
to Pete because he's winning you know a
lot of people are talking about him so
we'll just keep that going
you know what I mean
we just he's I'm saying he's gonna keep
the train going you know he'll probably
date somebody else Super Famous get a
tattoo get the tattoo covered or removed
and then move on to the next I mean the
guy's just like that sort of like I mean
he it just he just feels like a like
like an artist you know what I mean like
in every sense of that what you think of
like like an artist that lives in a loft
and he like closes himself in because
he's looking for inspiration like one of
those type artists that the kind of
artists that have they people have
parties for and he shows up late to show
his work and women are just like oh my
God he speaks to me but it's just like a
it's just like a white wall with a with
like and he and somebody threw some
watermelon seeds at it and and some red
paint and then you're just like oh my
God the the the the the the the the the
depth of this work you know and then
you're the kind of person you're like
what I what did he do you know what I
mean and he just feels like that type of
artist man and it's no slight it's just
sometimes sometimes you don't get it
sometimes you get it you know what I
mean like sometimes no matter how crazy
a person is you see them like Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise with the you know with his
women and uh and Oprah couch and the
Scientology and all this stuff you you
hear about all this stuff and you just
go damn he sounds weird but then you see
his movies and you see you you see his
acting and you feel the presence and you
go oh I get it
some people have that
and then some people have like an
untangible
sort of like weird existential thing
about them that you don't see but you
see that other people see and then you
go what
so that's what it is you know
it's like he got that thing he's just
one of these guys that you go is he like
model look good looking no you know what
I mean like you see when you go why is
he like is he falling you know but
whatever that thing that he has
we're standing on the sideline and then
we're looking at women and the women are
like oh he's got it and you're like
really
and you just you just don't understand
it he's one of those type of artists one
of those type of dudes that's got that
thing that you have to see through other
people because of their actions and the
way they're doing so the dude is winning
he got Mojo that's a good word thank you
uh bb-8 Droid he got the Mojo y'all
there's some sort of Mojo So
I don't know
you know what I mean yeah I feel you
somebody said hide Rachel yeah I was
like yeah he the kind of dude he the
kind of dude it don't care it don't
matter what you think he got you keep
your girl away from Pete Davidson okay
because you you don't be sitting here
being like nah my girl would never go
for that hey if my girl can go for this
oh
he could get it
you know what I mean he could get it
y'all
anyways I think that's a good stopping
point we got a new beat for the for the
rap recap y'all my boy Chris you
he sent me a bunch of Beats all the
producers are battling right now because
they see it they send them to me on
Tuesday mornings and I'm like oh yeah
it's the rap recap
give me some dab
or a fat fat
step up and get slapped
oh it's terrific Griffin
we always Revenge
got this big no sniffing
coaching that lane kissing
what we talk about today
talk about it every day
they like rookie
[Music]
they ain't good
maybe they misunderstood
[Music]
[Applause]
and I'm tough like
oh
talk about Pete
[Music]
I don't know what rhymes with open
like a sloping maybe he's doping oh this
is mythical Griffin
[Music]
Rob recap
step up and get slapped
like Draymond Green
the man sometimes mean
like Mean Joe Greene punching Jordan
pool like a obscene
it wasn't king
Eric Griffin getting lean
the rap we got
it's the rap recap
all right y'all shout out to Chris you
and everybody listening thank you for
being here
and you know what I forgot to do I
forgot to do my house of dragons I
forgot to do my She-Hulk because we live
and it just goes like that so look for
those things next week
because it's getting good just real
quick She-Hulk it really got good and
how's the dragons too many time jumps
right so we'll get into that next week
because I couldn't get to it because we
got into a big discussion but anyways
things thanks for watching we're from
with Griffin thanks for all the Beats
you want to send me a beat arrog at
ericgriffin.com I'm gonna be on Twitch
soon so come check me out there make
sure you follow subscribe hit the
notifications all right and thanks for
watching
Griffin with Griffin
yeah
foreign
[Music]